[Music]
what's up guys mkbhd here with possibly
the most requested video of all of 2018
so far shout out to linus from linus
tech tips because this is his phone
actually so thanks for passing it along
man this
is the oppo find x so this is actually
the hottest phone on the planet right
now
purely thanks to its really unique
design oppo actually has a history of
doing kind of insane things with
flagship phones but they don't do them
very often they specialize in the
mid-range but you might remember way
back in the day a couple years ago i
made a video about the oppo find 5 the
first ever 1080p smartphone that was a
huge deal and also the fine seven so
they do have a little history with
actually doing impressive flagship stuff
so now here in 2018 in this world with
lots of notches and compromise in walks
the oppo find x the specs even though
they're excellent are actually probably
the most boring part of this phone so
snapdragon 845 adreno 630 eight gigs of
ram 256 gigs of storage a 37 30 milliamp
hour battery bluetooth 5.0 dual sim
cards it's a flagship no doubt what
we're here for
is the design because that's the reason
this phone is so hot right now is the
industrial design on the surface it
looks
very modern obviously not a whole lot of
bezel anywhere that's the main focus in
2018 full screen rounded corners all the
way across the front of the phone but if
you look around even more there's
actually elegant touches everywhere the
shape is just a little unorthodox kind
of tapered on the sides but gives way to
this intense color design there's a blue
and a purple version actually this is
the purple which is called bordeaux red
for some reason and it has this shimmer
just on the outsides of the phone while
the middle stays dark mirror finish it
seems like the 28th thing to do also to
have a glass back
but no wireless charging that's also the
case for this phone but some awesome
design to distract you from that so the
huge screen up front obviously looks
super cool but even around that screen
they've done some things that are really
impressive and unique there's a little
earpiece up here in the top they
actually got a real speaker up there
instead of using an under glass solution
the whole phone is a little on the thick
side at nine millimeters but i'm totally
fine with this and for me it's more
about the solid weight like this phone
really feels dense in the hand with all
that glass there's no headphone jack at
the bottom or at all sadly but it has
this unique sort of concave shape with
the usb-c port speaker and the dual sim
card tray and man there's just a lot of
little unique touches like that the top
of the phone also has this shape of like
a liquid glass melting into itself
and there's no rear-facing or
front-facing camera at all
until you
yeah until you open the top
the entire top of this phone is
motorized for both the rear-facing and
front-facing camera sensors okay so to
achieve this
93.8
screen to body ratio in 2018 you got to
make some sacrifices so with this phone
there is no fingerprint reader anywhere
they didn't do the under glass one
there's no fingerprint anywhere on this
phone and then of course to do the
front-facing camera
they did i think one of the coolest
things i've ever seen in a smartphone
which is raise the whole thing via a
motor and it's it's different from the
next the next feels like a hack to just
get a front-facing camera in the phone
somehow
this feels like an integrated part of a
thoughtful design but now though you got
to think about again motorized moving
pieces in smartphones like this are
still a tough ask they eventually will
fail and they also make it harder for
things like ceiling and make it easier
to break and this is the whole top of
the phone popping up so i'm pretty sure
you can forget about waterproofing right
off the bat and then when you have this
much surface moving you think about
maybe if one grain of sand gets in there
that could be a problem too it's easier
than you think obviously oppo trust this
a lot though because as you can see they
have the rear camera which you use all
the time and the front camera and a
suite of other sensors including a dot
projector and an infrared sensor all up
here because this also does facial
recognition that's right so with no
fingerprint reader anywhere on this
phone like the iphone they built what
you might call a face id clone in those
front-facing sensors in the motorized
piece
here's the thing though
it's actually pretty fast if you check
that speed it's
possibly even faster than face id you
register your face in like three seconds
flat and then it's just look at the
phone to unlock it's actually pretty
cool it just pops up looks at your face
real quick and then goes back down all
in about half a second i'm impressed not
gonna lie i don't know if it's as secure
as face id i honestly kind of doubt it
but if it's not getting fooled easily or
tricked by photos then it's impressive
to me out the box this thing's crazy man
and you also have to consider when you
have the back facing camera which you
use all the time and the front facing
camera and the face unlock in that
motorized piece that means you're gonna
you're gonna use this every time you
open your phone
and hundreds more times during the day
so that's something to think about i
don't know how long this motor is rated
to last
but i'd be interested to see how long it
does also i tried a couple other things
just out of curiosity uh with this motor
if you push down hard enough the camera
just closes the motors just decide it
should be closing and it retracts
completely probably pretty smart
actually and then if you put enough
resistance on the top while opening the
camera and it's trying to launch by
itself it'll pause
wait a second
and then it'll try again
and then just keep holding it and it'll
just keep trying over and over it's not
really going to grind its gears trying
to go against resistance so it has a
couple failsafes built in but i also
found that i can literally pull the top
of the phone open
so you can imagine it's not the most
durable mechanism in the world if a
grain of sand gets in there like i said
that's probably bad news for more of the
internal parts and that just kind of
happens sometimes more than i wish it
did so at the end of the day i love this
actually i love what we're getting in
this genuinely interesting creative
design in a smartphone just when we
thought it might have been getting kind
of boring with everyone doing a notch
and dual cameras and the whole
predictable dance this thing comes in
from left field a new player has arrived
but i'm curious what you think if this
one came to your region it's gonna be
very expensive but could you rock this
as a daily driver i feel like i could
throw a nova launcher on here give the
camera a shot and it might actually stay
in my pocket but let me know what you're
thinking in the comments below either
way thanks for watching talk to the next
one
peace